In order to gain some insights into
designing future clinical trials,
and then also touch on some of the
evolving ideas around
drug development along the way with some of the technologies available now.
Going to see if I can
get some help to advance the slide.
I can't advance the slide.
Oh, okay. Great. These are my disclosures.
So the key messages here,
I want to
highlight how clinical and pre-clinical studies have informed on therapeutic
resistance as well as biomarkers of response.
And I think the other key point is the increase in number of novel
agents
are increasingly complex,
and we really need to start thinking about applying them in
the appropriate therapeutic setting, as well as
expanding this biomarker toolbox and how we're going to incorporate
newer technologies and AI into contemporary clinical trials.
So I wanted to start with an example in lung cancer,
where we've seen multiple generations of
EGFR TKIs being developed. And the fact is these
drugs have been found to be effective even from the very beginning,
where you actually can see really high response rates, ranging
from 60% all the way to 80%. That has been pretty
consistent, and it tells us a little bit about what the
limitations are, and that's
trying to understand the drivers
of disease progression. But also you can see quite consistently
that there are subsets of patients that are treatment
refractory even in the get-go, despite harboring
a driver alteration or predictive biomarker.
And again, I think part of it is really refining that
definition of resistance. And here you can see primary
resistance is, again, that scenario I just described.
And then there's a longer tail of secondary
resistance that
manifests as such, and again,
what we're beginning to appreciate is there's ongoing adaptation
over time, and this
adaptation eventually reaches
a bottleneck, and eventually you get competitive release
of resistant clones. And again,
the key is being able to understand this continuum
of resistance as we
want to design interventions. And to date, we
probably have been very much just focused on secondary resistance and basically
getting single snapshots on the resistance mechanisms
at the time of growth. And so I think the persistent biology is something
that really has been fairly elusive to date.
Now, if we talk about response and resistance, you can see
resistance...
Well, let's talk about response first.
EGFR mutations have been traditionally
associated with
the responses that we've seen.
We have also, in our lab, discovered
alternative mechanisms where you have, in a
non-mutated setting,
have long non-coding RNA EGFR that actually results in
increase in this isoform D that drives
ligand-related EGFR addiction.
And as I was mentioning earlier, primary resistance remains poorly
understood.
When you come talk about secondary resistance, these have been fairly
well documented, and I'll speak more of that in the subsequent slides.
It's suffice to say, I think the other commonality across all
kinase inhibitors is that we are seeing repeated patterns where you
either have novel on-target mutations, often
around the drug binding site, but also
genetic amplifications,
and bypass pathways with second drivers,
and this lineage plasticity state that was mentioned
and discussed elegantly in the
plenary in the first day.
Now,
what we know about resistance in terms of the genomics,
and frustratingly, despite quite
extensive genomic studies that have been performed largely
with broad panel-based DNA sequencing,
the usual suspects of
on-target mutations, some cMET amplifications,
HER2 amplifications were found, but these were relatively infrequent,
ranging between 10% to 25%.
And again,
a large proportion of resistance tumors remain
poorly understood. And I think that remains to be something
important for us to be able to unravel,
and I think therein also lies the
opportunity for novel
therapeutic agents in addressing this
resistance.
But also thinking broader around different types of
assays that can be applied here,
including gene expression assays as well as proteomic assays.
Shown here on the right in this particular study,
it was a proteomic panel of about 250 proteins, and you can
see in pre- and post-samples, they could characterize some of the
current proteins that are commonly featured in ADC
targets, potentially providing a rationale for using some of
these agents.So again,
if you talk about strategies currently used to
address resistance, we talk about next generation kinase inhibitors
that target some of these new on-target mutations,
combination therapy
with some of the
second drivers that we discover, as well as newer formats like bispecific
antibodies, trispecific antibodies, ADCs.
And a lot of advances in chemistry and antibody engineering
are leading to really quite innovative formats that are
entering the clinic. And the traditional paradigm really has been,
if you get initial data in the
Phase 1 that is
sufficiently efficacious, that may warrant
achieving accelerated approval.
And that then goes through the usual Phase
2, Phase 3, before it gets full approval.
Now, just a word of caution about,
again,
some of the early forays into using next generation
TKIs.
These
fourth-generation drugs were designed to target this
C797S resistance mutation, and you can
see, in fact, that
while there is pretty good
ctDNA response with quite significant
reduction in ctDNA levels,
the number of patients that actually achieve
responses, radiological responses, were more limited.
Again, highlighting
that even if you hit and inhibit the mutation,
sometimes that doesn't always translate to tumor responses,
and speaks to the potential for overlapping resistance
mechanisms as well as other ongoing
mechanisms such as lineage plasticity or lineage transition
states that we know have been also described in the
resistance setting.
Now, what about second drivers? And again,
some of these have had some early success
with cMET inhibitors. For example, in
cMET-amplified
setting, which occurs in about 15%, 20%.
And in this setting,
some trials are using five as a cutoff, some others are using 10, and it
really becomes a question of how you size out
the target population here. But again, I
think the challenge with this particular combination is
really
the Phase III concepts have been attempted twice now
in two companies, both Novartis as well as
Merck. But again,
I think because of the significant heterogeneity of resistance
as well as the challenge of re-biopsying
patients as they go on
for identification of cMET amplification,
those trials had to prematurely terminate.
The other phenomenon that we do see is the occurrence of second drivers.
So this, we can see ALK, RET, and this was an
experience that was reported with RET rearrangements,
showing efficacy with the combination with osimertinib and
selpertinib, another RET inhibitor.
And of course, the challenge with these is given that these are pretty rare events
and
how do we generate sufficient evidence to have
this become reimbursable
and approved in the local health system.
And to address this challenge,
one of the ways that we
addressed this was to set up an IRB-approved
evaluation protocol to facilitate access to off-label therapies.
And in this instance, we would either
directly reach out to industry to provide access to
some agents, or if they were available
already with another approved indication,
patients
would sometimes be willing to pay for it as well,
or insurance. And this shows some of the initial experience
with some of the alterations that we found.
And
here we have a case of a RET rearranged lung
cancer that we
added cMET inhibitors on because of a MET
amplification, showing some response
here.
Now, of course, there is also this evolving definition of progression, where
we would traditionally use clinical progressive disease.
Now, we
then use a RECIST criteria, which is an increase in
size of tumors, and increasingly
perhaps molecular progressive disease as well.
And even now, ctDNA persistence
is one of the potential settings that we may intervene.
And here we have a trial that's ongoing.
This is from North America. Lead principal investigator is Helena
Yu. And when patients that have
persistent EGFR ctDNA, the trial design
would be to add chemotherapy
on top of that to see if there's improvement in
progression-free survival in persistence.
Now,
I think the other thing to appreciate is that-A lot of the development
efforts are really very much focused in the refractory state.
And the key is really how we're going to be able to shift some of these
rationally into the frontline setting in stage four, but also
increasingly into the locally advanced and early-stage
disease setting. And perhaps even
thinking about whether some of these interventions can be used in the
pre-invasive setting with at-risk individuals, but I'll
go back to that later on again. And I think the priorities
here would really be to continue to develop
cost-effective therapeutic strategies, and again, this is
the example here with
ALK inhibitor, third generation lorlatinib, showing
a very impressive durable
progression-free survival, where the seven-year follow-up
is updated, it
will be presented at ASCO this year.
And in the early stage setting, improve risk stratification,
as well as
thinking about how best to incorporate perioperative strategies
into that setting. And I'll speak more to that
later. And there's opportunities for us to actually
rapidly transition some of these systemic therapies into that perioperative
setting. And even as we
ramp up
some of the efforts in early detection,
that will still increase the yield of early stage,
making the early stage setting across different cancers
going to be an important setting for us to really think about how
best to design interventions and to track them.
Now, when we talk about moving some of the second-line efforts
or the treatment refractory efforts into the frontline setting, I think we do need
to take into consideration
what we know about risk stratification.
So, if you look at some of the key
drivers of
disease progression and evolution, these can be
inferred sometimes from the mutations,
as well as some of the genomic features.
And ultimately,
I
guess over time, what we have begun to understand is that
with each of these subsequent generations of treatments,
we do also get a shifting resistance profile over
time, where if you look at the first generation drug, you still had
60% of EGFR-dependent disease, and this
was some work that we also demonstrated that in the
EGFR, the T790M-negative disease
actually had very little significant lineage
transition shifts with loss of adenocarcinoma
kind of phenotype.
And when you then follow up with a third generation drug,
you actually have still
a fair number of on-target
resistance mutation, and the unknowns is about a quarter.
But this actually significantly increases when you start now having the
frontline, third generation, highly potent EGFR inhibitor,
where 50% to 60% of patients actually
lack any known resistance mechanism, at least
on next-generation sequencing.
And again, this speaks to
what I was alluding to earlier, where when you now start off with a
very
potent inhibitor, this can lead to increasing lineage
transition that then contributes to the eventual resistance.
Now,
I think one of the emerging concerns as well is the
rational, well, I guess, increasing
enthusiasm for applying combinations upfront.
And here you can see several Phase III trials that have been
designed in this frontline setting, including the addition of
ADCs, so c-Met, EGFR, HER3
ADC. And
even
at the bottom here,
subsets of patients, poor-risk ones, for example, those with
concurrent P53 mutations or concomitant
co-drivers, have also gone into clinical studies,
again, trying to identify
poor-risk patients for
combination approaches.
I think with those studies that are
ongoing, one of the big challenges is going to be how
those trials are designed across the entire cohort, and
how you going to be able to, in
clinical practice, start identifying patients who are most likely
to benefit from these combination approaches.
And for this, I think improving our ability
to risk stratify patients in this setting here
with molecular
studies, we
could also identify and forecast potential
resistance mechanisms. And again, perhaps this is one of the
approaches that we may be able to adopt with
more routine use of molecular studies.
And in this study, we use both a combination of exome and
RNA-seq.
Now, we know that the genomic landscape can dictate some of the clinical
trajectories. And here,
we have demonstrated before how
when you haveMultiple core truncal
drivers
or in a more silent tumor, you can actually lead to
significant difference in the disease trajectory.
And again, these should be taken into consideration as
we think about the systemic therapy options.
More recently, we've embarked in trying to characterize some of
the copy number landscape, and just to share
even within EGFR, you can get distinct copy number
subcategories of diploid whole genome doubled,
and those that have
higher degrees of ploidy
as well as mutator phenotype, and these did seem to
be associated with different clinical outcomes.
And
when we then looked across some of the gene signatures
in terms of the patients that had higher risk of
relapse,
this was found to have enrichment for some of
the
TME-type stromal signatures
that included activated neutrophils,
tumor-associated endothelial cells, cancer-associated fibroblasts.
And again, this myeloid-skewed,
stromal-rich TME is really a phenotype
which maybe
could represent,
number one, a poor-risk population that would warrant escalation of
therapy, but also represent
ways that we can actually direct have now
stromal targeting agents which are already coming into
the clinic, such as FAP-targeting drugs and
radioligand therapy, for example.
There's ongoing effort to try to
better resolve some of the microenvironment features, and again, this is an example
of how we can apply some
newer technologies to better understand some of the
associations and the
ecotypes between the stromal-rich phenotype I
mentioned and another immune-inflamed subtype.
And again, the hope here is that this can actually
reveal, again,
opportunities for us to be able to
actually
use
immune-related directed therapies even
in these settings.
So that was on
the treatment-naive setting. What about the impact of
EGFR TKIs?
And here, in fact, when we
apply even effective therapies, there are
instances where here we can see a significant
increase in this GEP score.
And
when we deconvoluted some of the subsets,
you do see increased enrichment of CD8 as well as
macrophages, especially when this was analysis that was
done in purity-matched samples. And I think
this also was a phenomenon that we saw with some of the
other targeted therapies. For example, the KRAS G12C and
G12D agents where we do see this initial immune infiltrate.
And it does speak to whether there
are opportunities on treatment for us to be able to
time some of these combinatorial
approaches.
Just to also share how we
applied spatial transcriptomics into some of these
samples,
showing
identifying ligands
that may be implicated in this, particularly saw CD47
sub alpha, for which there are
CD47-directed therapies that may
encourage or overcome the "don't eat me"
macrophage
phagocytosis.
Going even deeper into this now, again,
what we were hoping to achieve here is to basically
understand both the impact of
the on-treatment samples as well as the
post-treatment samples and treatment-naive samples, and trying
to, again, compile some of the single-cell interactions
between each of these treatment states or these TKI treatment states.
And here you can see this is a representation of all the cells that
we identified in 36 patients.
And
I think quite interestingly, you can see that
in the TKI-resistant state, you have an increase in some of the
neuroendocrine features. But in the on-treatment state, there's
a developmental stem-like state that was characterized in
one of the proportion of the cells.
And one interesting analysis here is when you
start comparing across both the treatment-naive, on-treatment, and
TKI-resistant state and start trying to identify
some of the cell-to-cell interactions, you can see that each of the three
states actually can have very different cell signaling
kind of communication channels. And each of these,
again, we're looking into them more specifically in
order to identify whether there are therapeutic opportunities and certain
cell types that can be leveraged in this
settingOf course, we don't
basically do enough studies trying to
examine this on-treatment state.
But again, this was a study that we worked with
Novartis previously, and it was set up in 2019,
thereabout. And again, I think this type of trial
where we would start single-agent third-generation TKI, have
a biopsy, and then allocate to one of the
combination agents,
would be one of the ways forward. And again, this is
currently a manuscript in preparation
to share that initial experience.
I think it is a challenging space given that we do observe
high response rates. But I think
that on-treatment biopsy can yield some
hopefully unique insights into the biology.
Okay. So again, moving on to some of the
emerging trends. So I think in terms of the number of novel
agents with increasingly complex modes of action,
you can see here
with the increase in
protein degraders, TCRTs,
and radioligand therapies, novel antibody concepts, I think
these are
things to come.
And again, I borrowed this slide from Dr.
Jordi Rodon from MD Anderson, and you can see as
well that we've had many advances in both structural
biology as well as identification of novel peptides,
even bifunctional peptides, that can now have the ability to both hone
into specific targets, but also even
target essential proteins that were previously
thought to be difficult to drug, at least with small
molecules.
And I think with this increase in
novel agents and in fact
agents that have two or three-factor type of
therapeutic effects, for example, with
a target protein and an effector protein,
then it calls for the need for more
complex evaluation of
biomarker studies. So at the moment, as we covered earlier, a lot of the
mainstay sequencing is really just DNA-based panels.
Some immunohistochemical stains.
We started to incorporate RNA-seq, but
I
think with some of the
spatial relationships that may lend some insights
into
therapeutic combinations, I think that those are
technologies that we hopefully will be able to run to better characterize
the impact of the tumor microenvironment.
Now, I think the other point to discuss is really
how context is also extremely important.
And here, in fact, was one of the experiences
of using a IL-1 beta antibody
canakinumab, and that was initially found used in
a cardiovascular prevention trial and found to actually reduce
the incidence of lung cancer. And this was dose-dependent, so this was
pretty compelling.
And this led to Novartis to actually move into
a program where the adjuvant study, second line,
first-line study was performed in combination with
chemoimmunotherapy. And in both those studies, we
didn't see
any benefit at all, despite that compelling result in
reducing incidence of lung cancer.
And I think this really speaks to the differences
in
the transitions between pre-invasive disease to frank cancer,
where perhaps inflammation plays a bigger
role.
And when in a more invasive or metastatic
disease,
the impact of this
therapeutic, this biologic, becomes less important.
And again, I think we do recognize this sometimes even
in the frontline setting versus the treatment refractory setting, and it's just
something that
hopefully there are more efficient ways that we can actually address this
problem.
And here is an example of
an experimental method that
was conducted
by my colleague, Dr. Tam Wai Leong
in GIS and NCCS.
And here they developed an in vivo metabolic
CRISPR screen
of mice developing tumors. And in
this setting, they could actually
identify targets both at initiation in the tumor
lag phase, in the growth phase, as well as in the setting of
advanced cancers and metastatic phase.
And just a schematic here to illustrate
each of the different phases have got different metabolic vulnerabilities.
Again, speaking to the importance of actually understanding
the setting that we want to actually develop
or conduct these clinical trials on.
Now, the last part I wanted to cover is just really incorporating new
technologies into contemporary clinical trials.
And again, now we have a funnel
for looking into all the molecular data through molecular tumor
boards which incorporate a whole range
of different assays. This is
a typical kind of report that we-We end up getting where we
look at
expression levels,
signatures of potential response to immunotherapy,
and provide recommendations.
I think
beyond individual patient recommendations, being able to
create a database is actually key
and often an afterthought. But
it does allow us to be able to identify similar
patients as well as
track real-world outcomes and define molecular subsets,
and even more relevant as well is be able to
very
quickly be able to identify potential patients to enroll into clinical
trials,
and that can play a
very important role in ensuring
timely accrual and generation of data.
Also just using this slide as an illustration to highlight that often with
these databases, it's highly heterogeneous.
This is a snapshot of the 2,500 patients, and
you have a range of panels, DNA panel,
RNA seq, whole exome sequencing, liquid biopsies,
immunohistochemistry, FISH. And
there is a lot of manual curation going on,
which is really becoming increasingly
not really feasible.
And I think this is an area where we're now starting to develop
automated tools to be able to curate and extract some of this clinical data
from the EMR,
as well as hopefully being able to deploy AI
agents to actually facilitate some of the
manual research that we go on for each case in the tumor
board.
I put this figure up just to also highlight the shifting paradigm
from all-comers Phase III studies to
more selected groups. And I've mentioned about the important role of the
tumor board, but increasingly, it's also important to start
thinking about some of these endpoints beyond
progression-free survival and overall survival.
I include here things like ctDNA or markers
specific to pathway modulation. And I think the
key is being able to develop biomarkers that are specific to the mechanism of
the drug.
And
I think that we've now had some instances where we've raised the question
whether it's absolutely necessary to run a randomized Phase III
trial. And I think in this instance with a RET
inhibitor, we already had seen in the initial
Phase I experience higher overall response rates,
PFS of 18.4 months
across
different lines of therapy.
But Phase III trial here was done
and
this was obligatory in terms of what regulators were requesting
for. This was done over 103 sites, 23 countries,
and I think we learned not too much more
from the Phase I experience other than the fact that perhaps pembrolizumab
didn't really add anything in terms of the control
arm
outcomes. So again, I think it's something
that in this particular instance, even two Phase III
trials for two RET inhibitors were performed concurrently.
Again,
I think it's something that we should really think
about whether that's going to be the
requirement, especially given the number of
assets or novel molecules that are coming through the pipeline.
The other problem we have is with increasingly
efficacious therapeutics.
I
was
mentioning lorlatinib earlier, and you can see here this is five-year
survival where the median PFS really hasn't been reached.
And
if we really started to think of using a
next generation
ALK inhibitor in this setting,
this would require,
back of the envelope calculations,
perhaps more than 15 years before
that trial would read out. And again, this is
probably not something that any
endeavor-- It would be a difficult endeavor for any company to be
able to address.
And the question is whether there are subsets that we could really
identify, poor-risk subsets. And again, some of the approaches that I
mentioned earlier perhaps could be applied to try to really understand and
it really emphasizes the importance of getting good quality
baseline tissue even as we run
these clinical trials.
Some of the solutions, again, I think real world data with
a well characterized, molecularly characterized data set can
help in silico controls where again, you could
pull similar patients in these real world data sets.
And as I mentioned earlier, having that deeper understanding of
responders and non-responders
can really help to optimize patient selection as well as be able to
iterate.
And I think even as the trial goes on, being able to
iterate and adapt the clinical trials it progresses becomes important.
I think my last point I want to make is really about clinically relevant surrogate
endpoints.
I give the example here of ctDNA in the setting of perioperative therapy.
And here there have been a lot of discussion
about
the need to identify the contribution of components.
So trials have been now designed into these multi-arm studies trying
to... examine specifically each of these components
of
the neoadjuvants component or the
postoperative adjuvant so that we could really, again,
identify which was the major contribution.
I think
that's fine, and it does
involve quite a substantial number of patients,
and there may be more efficient ways to at least initially be
able to prioritize one of those
arms, perhaps. And here, I think with
some degree of risk stratification from the neoadjuvant therapy,
being able to actually identify
or develop
ctDNA assays that you could then track over time would be
key.
And even when you look at some of the current trials looking into escalation of
the adjuvant phase in non-PAQR patients,
there are multiple that are ongoing. This is just two of the examples.
Even the non-PAQR
state,
it's quite variable in terms of the prognosis.
It does vary, for example, whether it is
30% to 50% or 70% viable
tissue left.
And again, I think if we can correlate that some of
these baseline changes with MRD readouts,
and that could really be able to help us be able to
identify
each of these treatment arms that may have the biggest
effect and impact on modulating ctDNA.
I think the challenge here is really how do we
now develop these assays more robustly
in terms of the clearance of ctDNA,
as well as
measure the durability of that impact and
start incorporating things such as molecular disease-free survival
into these treatment paradigms.
So I think my take-home message here really is,
I think there's a need to continue generating representative
molecular insights to the specific setting that we are
developing
therapeutic assets on.
And
I think that's going to be one of the biggest
key
challenges that we have now, because if you
think about
how a lot of our targets are being discovered, it's really very much on
TCGA and publicly available data for which they're often
treatment naive rather than in a treatment refractory setting.
And so there may be a
lot of biology that we
really haven't been able to learn about or
to convert or to translate into therapeutic assets.
I think
as we start thinking about pre-cancerous states, early invasive cancers,
frontline setting, treatment refractory setting, again, I think each
of these states may require different
therapeutic
agents.
I think they need to do better in enhancing risk stratification, so it's not one
size fits all. And there's opportunity now to do it with
multimodal prospective profiling.
Some degree of functional validation would be important, and I didn't cover that in
this talk.
But I think the
whole range of different preclinical models, including genetically
engineered mouse, engineered mice models, as well as
patient-derived organoid cell line models that we could consider.
I think surrogate endpoints are super
critical moving forward, and I think as a community, we
really need to be able to validate and qualify these.
And there's really a
potential for increasingly personalization of therapeutic interventions,
where if we think about where we are at the moment, we are really just stratifying
patients for specific therapies.
We're thinking about how we're going to be able to plan
bespoke combinations at this point in time, but
perhaps in the near future, we'll be able to
incorporate all the data, biomarker data that we measure in a specific
tumor and really be able to design specific therapies,
drugs
around that particular profile.
And I think finally,
again, I think
regulatory and reimbursement frameworks really need to be discussed,
and I think one of the areas is really to have
regular dialogue and roundtable discussions with the local regulatory
agencies so that they can fully appreciate and
understand what the requirements of
oncology drug development would be.
So with that, thank you for your attention, and happy to have a discussion
and take some questions.
So you gave a very interesting and provocative talk,
and I think there are some tensions that need to be resolved.
And one of the key tensions is
it seems that
there's a logistical challenge to doing studies.
They're very expensive. They have to go into two dozen countries and
enroll hundreds and hundreds of people.
And if the
characterization of the people entering this study will
involve increasing molecular and
pathologic and other kinds of analyses, that will
only raise the cost of the studies.
Yeah.
And so then people who do studies say, "Well,
to recoup the cost, we need as broad
a population as possible."
I agree.
But the tension is that it seemed to be
subdividing so that you're going to generate multiple orphan
drug
applications, and
that has to be resolved logistically and
economically,
because scientifically, it all is attractive.
Yeah.
But I wanted to get your
thoughts on that tension.
So, I think you're spot on there, and I think that's
something that we fully recognize.
And in a way, part of that cost is
the current paradigm of traditional
drug development, where there's this obligation for going
through each phase of clinical trials and including this randomized trial,
where we then have this protracted follow-up for overall survival in
order to get certain agencies and health authorities to
approve and reimburse these aged drugs.
I think
we have to start off from the point of saying
whether that's something that
continues to be sustainable given the pace and the number of, and
the expansive explosion in the number of therapeutic
possibilities using with technology at the moment.
And maybe from that
point of view, again, argue that perhaps this
innovation cycle is going to be way too long to be able to
incorporate
some of the developments. Now, is there an alternative?
I don't think there's a charted path at the moment, but certainly,
it's sometimes a question of effect size,
and I think if we can start to generate
significant clinical efficacy in a small cohort and demonstrate
some proof of concept that this
high-resolution profiling and matching
has some merit, then maybe that would be something, an
approach that we could consider.
So again, I think it's
going to be an evolving space, and we really need to,
again, as a community, discuss what's going to be the best way
forward.
Okay.
I'll be happy to follow up and have a discussion
after the talk. But I think with that, let's close the session,
and I appreciate
everyone being here and have a good rest of the meeting.
Thank you.